[Musica]
oggi stiamo vivendo un momento di
trasformazione epocale e questo riguarda
evidentemente le nuove tecnologie e avrà
a che fare non solo con le imprese in
particolare le aziende manifatturiere ma
anche la capacità dell'uomo di stare sul
pianeta
vi siete mai chiesti come cambierà la
nostra società
io mi occupo di innovazione per le
aziende da oltre 20 anni e
inevitabilmente anche le tecnologie sono
diventate nel tempo una mia passione ma
oggi non sono qui per darvi delle
risposte del resto nessuno
la risposta a questa domanda sono qui
piuttosto per agevolare con voi una
riflessione che ci porti a capire come
vivere questo cambiamento da
protagonisti le tecnologie a cui faccio
riferimento in particolare sono i robot
collaborativi i big data
il cloud computing l'internet delle cose
e naturalmente anche l'intelligenza
artificiale che probabilmente tra tutte
le tecnologie è sicuramente quella più
dirompente che oggi abbiamo a
disposizione
gli esperti parlano della quarta
rivoluzione industriale quando si
riferiscono a queste tecnologie
siamo di fatto all'interno di una my hat
on
anzi la quarta milestone del processo di
trasformazione dell'economia
dell'industria della nostra società
ecco io nei brevi minuti che avrò con
voi vorrei riflettere su tre argomenti
in particolare come quali sono le
caratteristiche di questa quarta
rivoluzione industriale
qual è la differenza tra intelligenza
umana e intelligenza artificiale e
infine come potrà evolvere la nostra
società in una sorta di rinascimento
digitale bene partiamo dal primo
klaus schwab il fondatore e presidente
del world economic forum ha dichiarato
che questa rivoluzione industriale e
probabilmente la rivoluzione delle
rivoluzioni e qualcosa che l'umanità non
ha mai visto prima
ci sono delle caratteristiche che non si
sono mai presentate la velocità le
precedenti rivoluzione industriale hanno
avuto una crescita lineare nel tempo
questa invece una crescita esponenziale
portate intensità le precedenti di
voluta industriali hanno caratterizzate
da una tecnologia soltanto le palle di
watson regolare il vapore nella prima
rivoluzione industriale
thomas edison che inventa l'energia
elettrica nella seconda rivoluzione
industriale e infine a federico faggin
un vicentino come me che inventa nella
sitcom vale il microprocessore e dà vita
al computer di base nella terza
rivoluzione austria le la quarta
rivoluzione dustriale una pluralità di
tecnologia e quello che ho detto prima
che si combinano con ulteriore tecniche
come la genomica piuttosto che le nano
materie e tutto questo produce ulteriore
innovazione e infine l'impatto sui
sistemi come ho detto inizio all'inizio
questa è una rivoluzione che non
riguarderà soltanto le imprese soltanto
l'industria l'economia ma gli interi
sistemi e quindi anche il pianeta e
quindi la nostra società è a questo
punto quindi molti di voi si staranno
chiedendo e qual è il ruolo dell'uomo
all'interno di questo cambiamento
prima di rispondere a questa domanda
però vorrei introdurre il secondo tema
quello dell'intelligenza artificiale
io ho avuto la fortuna il piacere un
paio d'anni fa di partecipare al summit
della singularity university
non so se la conoscete dell'università
americana privata sostenuta niente popò
di meno che da google che si occupa di
tecnologia esponenziale gli scienziati
della figura riti universiti affermano
con certezza secondo loro che nei
prossimi 10 massimo 20 anni
l'intelligenza artificiale riuscirà a
superare l'intelligenza umana
la prima volta che ho sentito questa
cosa mi sono venuti i brividi
poi però ho avuto la fortuna di
conoscere federico faggin proprio quel
fa gene che ha inventato il
microprocessore e due mesi fa lo ha
intervistato all'università di parma
durante la presentazione del suo ultimo
libro silicio dove spiega in maniera
molto forte come una macchina non potrà
mai superare l'uomo
il libro è molto complesso addirittura
scomoda la fisica quantistica però io ho
ricavato un esempio che portano anche a
voi l'esempio della rosa immaginate una
rosa un computer può già riconoscere la
rosa per esempio con la visione
piuttosto che il naso elettronico
sentendone
ma soltanto l'uomo può sentire il
profumo e cogliere delle sensazioni
uniche quelle sensazioni che sono solo
la coscienza dell'uomo può in qualche
modo esprimere
è questa la differenza sostanziale tra
una macchina e l'uomo ed emotivo perché
una macchina non potrà mai superare
l'uomo però di fatto la tecnologia
spaventa questi sono dati dell'ocse
recentissime che riguardano proprio
l'italia
un terzo dei lavori e ad alto rischio
cambiamento
metà di questi ad alto rischio
automazione e quando mi riferisco
all'automazione non mi riferisco
semplicemente i lavori più semplici
quelli manuali ma mi riferisco
addirittura i lavori d'ufficio
l'ha detto il telemarketing l'assistente
regale l'ha detto alla contabilità e
allora probabilmente dobbiamo immaginare
un mondo diverso e cambiare prospettiva
non pensare alla tecnologia in
sostituzione dell'uomo come ci hanno
insegnato per esempio i tedeschi varando
il piano industria 4.0 nel 2011 ma
immaginare una nuova società dove la
tecnologia è a servizio dell'uomo e
questo mi consente di entrare nel terzo
punto prendo spunto dal primo ministro
abbia giapponese nel 2016 per la prima
volta ha parlato di quinto stadio di
evoluzione della società
la sos haiti 5.0 ha immaginato una super
smart society dove l'intelligenza
artificiale aiuta le persone a stare
meglio sul pianeta
immaginate una società in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale riesce ad
abbattere qualsiasi barriera culturale
linguistica
immaginate una società in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale riesce ad
abbattere la burocrazia
immaginate una società in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale dati in mano
alla medicina riesce a predire le
eventuali malattie
ecco questa è la cosa straordinaria che
le tecnologie possono fare dall'altra
parte dall'altra parte dell'oceano gli
stati uniti stanno facendo ragionamenti
analoghi in particolare 200
amministratori delegati delle più
importanti società e ci stanno che
stanno alla borsa di new york hanno
sottoscritto un protocollo d'intesa dove
per la prima volta dichiarano che non è
più il profitto
tanto l'ultimo fine delle aziende
parlano di sostenibilità ambientale
naturalmente ma parlano anche di qualità
della vita dei propri lavoratori
e allora probabilmente ci stiamo
effettivamente affacciando una nuova
civiltà e quindi va dalla conclusione
come cambierà la nostra società e la
domanda da cui sono partito io vi ho
detto all'inizio non ho risposte
voglio con voi però fare un auspicio un
augurio a tutti noi abbiamo la
possibilità di ripercorrere il passato
pensate a gutenberg 500 anni fa quando
inventato la stampa e confrontatelo con
la potenza dell'internet oggi e
dell'internet delle cose popolarità
delle informazioni che oggi stanno
propagando pensate alle scoperte
dell'america con cristoforo colombo e
quello che sta succedendo oggi con la
globalizzazione
ecco probabilmente siamo agli albori di
un nuovo rinascimento non più delle arti
un rinascimento della scienza e della
tecnica e l'auspicio che do a tutti voi
e che l'italia nel 1400 è stata la culla
di questo rinascimento e quindi
auguriamoci che ancora una volta noi
italiani grazie all'intraprendenza ma
soprattutto alla creatività
all'intelligenza che ci contraddistingue
siamo capaci di rinascere nuovamente
grazie
[Applauso]